الى دراما حيث يحقق الموسم الثالث من
مسلسل الموت ثلاثه نجاحا كبيرا وتفاعلا من
قبل الجمهور لا يقل عن النجاح الذي حققه
العمل في المواسم الماضيه شخصيات جديده
باحداث دراميه مثيره تشد المشاهد في رمضان
اكدت مؤلفه المسلسل نادين جابر ان الجزء
الثالث استكمال لاحداث الجزء الاول
والثاني منه فهو متصل ومنفصل عنها في ذات
الوقت
اذا بعد كل شي صار ما تركتيه بحياتك ما
راح تتركيه
انت بدك تبقي معه ومعي بنفس الوقت
انا العيشه خلصنا
اولا انت ككاتبه الموت 3 او الموت واحد
واثنين وثلاثه كيف هو شعورك بهذا النجاح
اللي حققه وشو سر هذا النجاح وهل التكامل
بين الاجزاء اكيد النجاح حلو خاصه لما
يكونوا بعد تعب وتحدي واسرار والمسؤوليه
كانت كتير كبيره خاصه بهذا الجزء الحمد
لله عم بتكون كتير روعه ومبسوطين كلنا
كفريق عمل السر هم نجاح هو الخلطه بين
فريق العمل ككل انا ما بقدر انسب نجاح
مسلسل لشخص واحد بل هو فريق عمل كامل
متكامل بدي انا من النص
للاخراج للممثلين للانتاج هول العناصر
الاربعه ضروريه يكونوا بحيا لمسلسل لحتى
يكون ناجح واذا حيا لعنصر كان اقل
غلط بالنتيجه اها بس نادين نحنا نحكي عن 3
اجزاء اليوم فكيف يعني تمكنتي من
[موسيقى]
فكان في ضروره انه ضروره دراميه بحثه انك
تفل من لبنان تروحي على بلد ثاني وتفوتي
بشخصيات جديده
للتغيير ولقتولات الدراميه ونفوت بمسلسل
منصر ومنفصل بزيت الوقت لانه لو كنت انا
فتت في الجزء الثالث بذات الحلقه اللي درت
فيها بالحلقه الثانيه كنت كنت قشطت وكنت
يمكن الناس حبوا حلقه واثنين وثلاثه
واربعه وخمسه رجعوا حسوا بالملل وتركوا
المطور
[موسيقى]